[Applause]
yo
miami uh miami got a little wild this
past weekend guys
you know miami's been wild uh
it's been open it's been an incredible
experience but spring break came through
did you see the videos well do you see
it in real life at all no i've been out
of town
since thursday or whatever yeah did you
see it in real life
i mean i just saw kids like walking
around and like swats of people doing
[ __ ] i saw videos of like that kid
running from the cops
yeah that was funny so basically what
happened is spring break
right and um i don't know why kids need
a break they've been on break
they haven't gone to school you've been
on break this whole time but
need to hang out with friends i think
probably yeah but they've been hanging
out i mean we all hang out
i think it's just a cultural thing that
kids want to experience and they're
going to go to a place that's open and
there's few places in the world right
now that are as open as florida
is this like their woodstock what do you
mean like woodstock was just
it's like this moment you need to be a
part of this is spring break during
covent in miami the only place that's
open on the beach let's all just [ __ ]
hang out and get wild well yeah i think
i think maybe man i i think what it is
is like
i think we're getting a glimpse into
what post corona
america is going to be like yeah i think
you're right because people
are done with the quarantine yeah
they're done with lockdowns
they're over even if they know there's
potential that could kill their family
members
or they could be killed themselves
they're they've reached their limit i
think everybody has a limit you know you
can only hold people back so much before
they start to revolt you know
uh so they went to a place where they
could party and then miami shut that
[ __ ] down
they said 8 p.m curfew all the
restaurants i think got to close at 7
30. this is in south beach specifically
right
which is kind of dumb because then they
just spill over into like win wood
yeah right and they spin over spill over
to these other areas and now they're
gonna be absolutely [ __ ] crazy but
like there were girls like
riding on top of [ __ ] lamborghini
wild dogs working with their [ __ ] out
and [ __ ] like that people and she was
freaknik yeah it was freak nick bro
yeah it was freak i think only black
people are on spring break this year
right
i haven't seen the white people do you
see white people out there spring break
yeah there was some white people but
their spring break was
the week before i'm telling you i'm
saying black people are even late to
spring break
there's two spring breaks yeah there's a
black spring break
nah like you told me like the middle
america is a week before
oh yeah that is the coast yeah yeah like
midwestern schools will do it earlier
because it's cold
and so like they're like yeah go to the
beach or whatever interesting that's how
they used to do it for some reason they
kept the same schedule even though
everyone's at home yeah
okay so everybody's out here they're
wild and they're like they're not even
going they're like going to restaurants
not paying
running out do you see anything i mean i
just saw these videos that were crazy
and i saw my i went to this boxing match
i want to talk about that later but i
went to this boxing match
this this weekend and my coach the guy
who trains me shouts to donato
he lives i guess in south beach and it
took him four
hours to get from the boxing match back
home
people were driving off the highway onto
the grass
and then on to i guess other highways
yeah
like do you see videos of that that was
the craziest thing
i'm not talking about there's a little
patch of grass on the side of the
highway which is
there's zero gradient they were driving
down
the gradient the [ __ ] yeah it was insane
it was just bumper-to-bumper locked down
and the cops were like restricting a lot
of access to certain streets to prevent
people from coming to
south beach it was just creating like
crazy backup you were there for that or
no you were just reading about that from
videos as well like i saw just cop just
blocking off a whole highway yeah you
can't go
towards south beach i mean and it's like
it was just bumping the bumper some
ubers were crazy expensive like
that even in wynwood that same night it
was saturday night people were going
nuts yeah you think the bars are happy
like they're happy but they're concerned
i asked one
and i was like so this is good for you
he they're like he's like it's good but
like we need to get security
like yeah you know what time you're one
bad interaction away from everything
going to [ __ ]
right because it's gonna be like spring
break is is [ __ ]
it's wild yeah like all these kids are
so drunk they're all cocained up they're
not even thinking about their actions at
all they're really there to like let
loose i remember
myself on spring break like i was a wild
ass boy like just stealing [ __ ] for no
[ __ ] reason
and you had access to partying every
week
i just feel like yeah why did you do
that there's a cool mug
or something like that like i just steal
[ __ ] when it was done to steal like i'm
drinking out of this
deal why not just twerk on a cop car
yeah
yeah dude you're gonna break the law do
it like sexy
i need to learn how to be more felonious
yeah but in a sexy way okay uh
so basically i guess what i'm wondering
right now is like is this what corona is
gonna be
or this what life is gonna be after
corona i think it's gonna be some level
excited to like get out it's gonna be
the wildest the craziest summer we've
ever seen
probably yeah this [ __ ] is gonna but is
it the summer and then when is it and
how are they gonna play it because
[ __ ] are ready to go like if
this is florida and obviously these are
people coming from other places but
it seems like the places they're coming
from have to be locked down so because
this is the behavior when they come to
freedom
what is going to happen in new york new
york going to be nuts
let's go i i'm one of these people who
like if i own a nightclub
in new york i'm trying my hardest to
ride it out until then
yeah because that [ __ ] is gonna be
packed so here's the thing all these
nightclubs close
all these going out dancing party places
are closed we're gonna have less places
to go
and way more people that want to go yes
so the places that are open
are going to make a [ __ ] killing who
else can make a lot of money security
i'll charge whatever the [ __ ] i feel
like you could have it or you could not
yeah this [ __ ] is like gas when there
was a terrorist attack
everybody's like you don't know if
you're getting more of this this is a
supply limited
but it is interesting right like to see
all these people just going [ __ ]
berserk
they need it yeah that's the i wonder if
people are going more crazy or if
there's just a higher concentration of
kids
you know what i mean like i think it's
both because there's fewer places to go
they're just all coming if you think
about what did we do when we came down
here yo
first night first night we went to the
most compact
closed restaurant that we could yeah and
your [ __ ] has got kovitz
we stood at the bar with other people
like that was the policy the restaurant
the restaurant
went and they were like hey can you just
stand in that crowd
we went from special distance in new
york like if you don't wear a mask on
the street these old white [ __ ] are
going murderer
to walk into a restaurant and their
their policy
was we don't have your table ready could
you stand in a horde
with other people oh yeah and drink with
your mask off oh yeah they just say take
your mat
they say keep your mask on they go go by
the bar where you can drink
and be masculine yeah it's crazy but
also we're coming from new york
like all like there are some of these
kids that come from the midwest coming
from alabama or something but they
probably can't party like they used to
party in college so they don't have that
outlet that pressure releases and then
it's all just built up and now it's the
biggest party they've been to in their
lives yeah that's true they're gonna go
[ __ ] berserk
right around spring break last year so a
lot of
pent spring spring break energy right
now going on yeah that's true there's a
lot of college kids
who were like oh man i'm not going to
get my spring break because when you
think about it if you spring break
in america you got to be 21.
for the most part [ __ ] are not
taking a flight getting a hotel
to maybe be able to go to the bar i was
17 18 in cancun
but that's why i said america oh yeah
you know what i mean so it's like if you
if you're gonna go down for florida you
probably gotta have id
yeah and they're way more strict
nowadays than they were when we were
kids where you could like fake your
little id and [ __ ] now you gotta insert
your id into some piece of technology
you could just be any indians
hand another id to another spot they
wouldn't know dead ass
every anyone just trade ids and they
just get it and they just get it like
that
that's funny but my point is like
[ __ ] are out here bro yeah and
it's just it's i don't know there's
it sucks that they're tearing up miami i
don't like that but i am
excited at the enthusiasm
to party amongst like
the general public like it's cool to me
that people want to be out they want to
be around each other
and the second things open up we're
going to get back to normal
oh yeah cause that was i guess a little
bit of fear it's like how much of this
lingers like
you know people go is this what life's
gonna be are we not gonna want to be
around people are we gonna be social
distance forever we're gonna have our
masks on
and this just proves that the second the
government says you don't gotta wear a
mask
the second the government says you ain't
got a social distance the second a
government says you could go out to the
bar
the [ __ ] is gonna be jam-packed like if
if china's planning to
release another virus do it day one of
the opening
because everybody's gonna get infected
oh yeah
like if they got another one cooking up
in a lab right there and you want to
shut [ __ ] down again
day one uh-huh it's gonna look like
miami was yeah
um yeah that [ __ ] was wild but also how
boring are we that there's like [ __ ]
woodstock happening in miami and no one
saw it at all so once the gunshots
happened
i was good bro i'm 36 now i'm so good
so we would just start a boat living it
up like yeah yeah i guess
doing it bro we should have spring break
that's how rich people party let's just
get
on the water away from the poor people
let them have their little fun
we took we took a bus that's real
birthday wish out happy birthday
i missed it buddy love you man and uh i
guys don't want to be part of [ __ ]
you're out of town i asked them to come
to nashville it does this weekend
yo now we added another show
yo go get tickets to that by the way if
it's still available i don't know if it
is but do that right now
uh if you couldn't get tickets to those
shows but he don't even want to come bro
he never want to hang out there why not
i gotta go i'm gonna go where he's
going in the northeast what does that
mean northeast like that's how you know
you got to do that
why'd you do that that's how you play
some super
[ __ ] where you just described the region
of america i mean the northeast
yeah where in the northeast you gotta go
i'm getting my second vaccine
why don't you say that i don't i don't
know just something like i'm just going
to the northeast who says that i'm going
to the northeast like what are you doing
tonight i'm going to the southwest it's
also way more in miami
you're from the northeast yeah
i don't know if you understand how it
works
it's like a vague you know what i mean
it's like a vagrant to the northeast
that's what people that are from like
shitty countries when they just say the
biggest one next yeah that's what you
just did to me yeah yeah they just
didn't want to say you're going to get
your vaccine again
yeah what day are you going to get your
vaccine friday why friday
because i want to make sure i hit both
podcasts while they're doing wednesday
or thursday so friday
damn bro all right wow [ __ ]
still don't want to come to nashville
we're there the whole weekend we're
there the whole weekend you can get your
little shot and hop on a plane to hit us